"
♪ ♪
PRESIDENT BIDEN TRYING TO
CONTROL YOUR LEGACY ON
SOCIAL MEDIA.
THE WHITE HOUSE BOASTING ABOUT
HOW IT'S TEAMING UP WITH THE BIG
TECH PLATFORMS LIKE FACEBOOK TO
FLAG, QUOTE, "PROBLEMATIC POSTS"
ABOUT COVID-19.
AS ADMINISTRATION STAFFERS ARE
WORKING TO POLICE CONTENT ON
NINE
ONLINE.
>> THERE IN REGULAR TOUCH WITH
THE SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS.
LEAVE INCREASED DISINFORMATION
RESEARCH AND TRACKING WITHIN THE
SURGEON GENERAL'S OFFICE,
FLAGGING PROBLEMATIC POSTS FOR
FACEBOOK THAT SPREAD
DISINFORMATION.
>> Jesse: DESPITE THE BACKLASH
AND CONCERNS IT COULD LEAD TO A
CRACKDOWN ON SPEECH, DOUBLING
DOWN DURING A CLASS WITH OUR VEY
OWN PETER DOOCY.
>> FOR HOW LONG HAS
ADMINISTRATION BEEN ON FACEBOOK
PROFILES LOOKING FOR VACCINE
DISINFORMATION?
>> THAT WAS QUITE A LOADED AND
INACCURATE QUESTION, WHICH I
WOULD REFUTE.
PETER, FIRST OF ALL, AS YOU
KNOW, WE ARE IN REGULAR TOUCH
WITH A RANGE OF MEDIA OUTLETS,
AND --
LET ME FINISH.
AS WE ARE IN REGULAR TOUCH WITH
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS.
>> THERE'S BEEN CONCERN, FOR A
LOT OF PEOPLE ON FACEBOOK, THAT
NOW THIS IS BIG BROTHER WATCHING
YOU.
>> THEY ARE MORE CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT THAN PEOPLE DYING ACROSS
THE COUNTRY BECAUSE OF A
PANDEMIC WHERE MISINFORMATION IS
TRAVELING ON SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS?
>> Jesse: AND JOE BIDEN AND
THIS VERY STRONG ACTION.
>> COVID MISINFORMATION, WHAT IS
YOUR MESSAGE TO PLATFORMS LIKE
FACEBOOK?
>> THERE KILLING PEOPLE.
I MEAN, LOOK, THE ONLY PANDEMIC
WE HAVE IS THE ONE AMONG THE
UNVACCINATED.
AND THEY ARE KILLING.
>> Jesse: JESSICA, IF YOU ARE
A GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL, YOU CAN
CRACKDOWN ON FREE SPEECH AND
JUST SAY, "YAY, SAVING LIVES.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE AWAY YOUR
FIRST AMENDMENT.
SAVING LIVES."
>> Jessica: I DON'T SEE HOW
THIS IS CRACKING DOWN ON THE
FIRST AMENDMENT.
THE STUDY THAT JEN PSAKI CITED
WAS PUBLICLY AVAILABLE, IT WAS
PUBLISHED IN MAY, COVERED BY A
RANGE OF OUTLETS THAT SAID THERE
WERE 12 MAIN ACCOUNTS SPREADING
65% OF THE DISINFORMATION ABOUT
COVID-19.
WE CAN ALL GOOGLE.
I DID GOOGLE IT.
THAT'S FOR US TO SEE.
WHEN HE POSTS ON FACEBOOK, I
DON'T HAVE AN ACCOUNT, THAT IF I
DID I WOULD POST AND IT WOULD BE
PUBLIC, AND THERE COULD BE
PEOPLE IN THE GOVERNMENT OR
PRIVATE ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES THAT HAVE
A RESPONSIBILITY TO KEEP PEOPLE
AS SAFE AS POSSIBLE.
COVID DISINFORMATION GETS PEOPLE
KILLED.
>> Greg: DOESN'T MATTER.
>> Jesse: BUT DO YOU THINK THE
WHITE HOUSE SHOULD BE IN CHARGE
OF LABELING WHAT IS
DISINFORMATION?
THE
THEY HAVE A HORRIBLE TRACK
RECORD WHEN IT COMES TO WHAT
DISINFORMATION IS.
>> Jessica: I'M NOT SURE THEY
HAVE MUCH OF A TRACK RECORD.
THEY'VE ONLY BEEN IN FOR A FEW
MONTHS.
>> Jesse: OPEN BORDERS,
LAPTOPS --
>> Jessica: SETTING MML --
>> Jesse: RUSSIANS.
HOAX.
>> Jessica: LET ME FINISH.
>> Jesse: I WILL PUT A
HYPOTHETICAL OUT AND GREG CAN
ANSWER.
WE WEREN'T GETTING ANYWHERE.
LET'S SAY PRESIDENT TRUMP, A
COUPLE YEARS AGO, COLLUDED WITH
FACEBOOK TO CRACKDOWN ON PEOPLE
POSTING ABOUT THE RUSSIA HOAX.
HE SAID, "THE END AND IS POSTING
ABOUT THAT, THAT'S
DISINFORMATION, IT'S TEARING THE
COUNTRY APART, LET'S NUKE 'EM.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THEY WOULD
HAVE SAID?
>> Greg: THAT'S A REALLY GOOD
ANALOGY.
NONE OF THIS MATTER IS, ONCE
GOVERNMENT IS INVOLVED WITH A
CORPORATION, THAT IS A VIOLATION
OF THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
IT IS A MATTER PEOPLE BELIEVE
IT'S DISINFORMATION.
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
BECAUSE IT IS --
EVERY OPINION COULD BE
MISINFORMATION BY OUR
DEFINITION.
THAT'S WHAT THE FIRST AMENDMENT
IS, COMING OUT AND SAYING YOUR
OPINION.
I DON'T TRUST THIS GOVERNMENT.
I DO TRUST YOU, JESSICA, BUT I
DON'T TRUST MOST DEMOCRATS IN
DEFINING WHAT MISINFORMATION IS,
TO JESSE'S POINT.
IMAGINE THE PEOPLE -- LOOK IT UP
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE.
IMAGINE PEOPLE WHO SPENT DECADES
CALLING US STUPID, RUBES, AND
RACIST, ARE CONTROLLED DUMB AT
CONTROLLING THE SPREAD OF
INFORMATION BY USING THE WORD
"MISINFORMATION."
ANY SANE PERSON WOULD SAY HELL
NO, BILLY DON'T EVEN HAVE TO SAY
HELL NOW.
WE CAN SAY WE ARE TOTALLY WRONG.
IT DOESN'T MATTER, IT'S A
VIOLATION OF THE
FIRST AMENDMENT.
YOU CAN USE IT AGAINST ANY
REPUBLICAN CONSERVATIVE
ARGUMENT.
DEFENSE OF LAW ENFORCEMENT, YOU
WANT BLACKS TO DIE.
DEFENSE OF CAPITALISM, YOU WANT
THE POOR TO DIE.
DEFENSE OF SCHOOL CHOICE, YOU
WANT TEACHERS TO DIE.
IT CAN BE BASED ON THE FACT
THAT, "WE WANT PEOPLE TO DIE,"
HE CAN CONTROL THE
MISINFORMATION.
TO USE THIS ARGUMENT, THERE
KILLING PEOPLE TO CONTROL YOU.
WHEN INFORMATION COMES OUT AND
IT'S WRONG, IT'LL BE WRONG ON
THE LEFT AND ON THE RIGHT.
THAT DOESN'T MATTER.
THE COLLUSION IS WHAT MATTERS.
>> Jesse: HERE'S WHAT I THINK
HAPPENS, SHANNON.
THE WHITE HOUSE REALLY SCREWED
UP THE JOHNSON & JOHNSON
SITUATION.
HE SAW WHEN THEY CAME OUT AND
THEY'S BREAD ABOUT THE
VACCINATION RATES PLUMMETING, N.
NOW HE DOESN'T MEET HIS JULY 4TH
GOAL FOR VACCINES.
THEN, "IT'S YOUR FAULT."
"WE'RE GOING TO GET RID OF YOU."
>> Shannon: REMEMBER, JUST A
COUPLE WEEKS AFTER
PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS INAUGURATED,
THERE WAS A PIECE IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND PEOPLE
LAUGHED IT OFF OR WHATEVER, BUT
THEY TALK TO EXPERTS AND SAID,
WE NEED A REALITY CZAR.
A FULL GOVERNMENT RESPONSE
ACROSS AGENCIES, PEOPLE MEET,
THEY LOOK FOR DISINFORMATION,
THEY SHOOT IT DOWN, IT'LL GO
THROUGH THE REALITY CZAR, WILL
THEN MEET WITH THE HEADS OF BIG
TECH.
THEN WHEN THE STUFF COMES UP
PEOPLE I LIKE, "MAYBE THAT'S
ACTUALLY WHAT THEY'RE DOING."
IT GIVES LYNN TO THE SAILS
FORMER PRESIDENT TIMES LAWSUIT
AGAINST THESE COMPANIES WHEN HE
SAID THEY ARE ACTING AS
GOVERNMENT ACTORS.
IF IT LOOKS LIKE THERE IS
COORDINATED ACTIVITY BETWEEN THE
GOVERNMENT AND BIG TECH, IT ONLY
HELPS HIS ARGUMENT IN COURT.
SEE LINES OF THE WHITE HOUSE
PRESSURING MONOPOLIES TO TAKE
OUT POLITICAL SPEECH THEY
DISAGREE WITH.
>> Shannon: RIGHT, THAT'S THE
POINT YOU ARE MAKING ABOUT THE
COLLISION.
THE LEGAL ARGUMENT IS
ESSENTIALLY THAT THE GOVERNMENT
HAS DEPUTIZED THESE SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS.
ALLOWING IT TO SERVE AS AN ARM
OF THE GOVERNMENT, AND THEREFORE
IT IS STATE SANCTIONED
CENSORSHIP.
WHY IT IS SO DANGEROUS, THE
PUBLIC RESPONSE TO IT.
IT'S TWOFOLD.
HERE POINT, THE COMMON CARRIERS
THAT THE GOVERNMENT HAS GRANTED
SPECIAL STATUS TO, SPECIAL
FAVORS, THE LAW THEN SEES THEM
AS QUASIGOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES.
THEY ARE IN A DISTINCT CATEGORY.
THEY ARE NOT THIS PRIVATE
COMPANY.
JUSTICE CLARENCE THOMAS POINTED
OUT, HE SAID TWITTER HAS MADE
CLEAR THE RIGHT TO CUT OFF
SPEECH LIES MOST POWERFULLY IN
THE HANDS OF PRIVATE DIGITAL
PLATFORMS.
THEN HE WENT ON TO SAY -- I'M
PARAPHRASING -- THAT IT GETS SO
DIRTY AND MESSY WHEN IT'S A
FIRST AMENDMENT ISSUE BECAUSE
THE GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN
INTERTWINED WITH THEM NOW.
I THINK JEN PSAKI'S STATEMENTS
IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE FORMER
PRESIDENT LAWSUIT MEANS THAT THE
TIME IS NOW.
THE COURTS WILL NOT RULE IN
THEIR FAVOR.
>> Jesse: I'M GOING TO GIVE
YOU THE LAST WORD BECAUSE I DID
RUDELY INTERRUPTED, JESSICA.
NO ONE GOT IN MY EAR!
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jessica: NOW I'M WASTING MY
TIME!
>> Jesse: THE CLOCK IS
TICKING.
>> Jessica: THIS IS OBVIOUSLY
NOT THE FIRST ADMINISTRATION TO
HAVE A MEETING WITH
MARK ZUCKERBERG OR WITH
JACK DORSEY.
THIS HAS HAPPENED UNDER
REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRATIC IN
ADMINISTRATIONS.
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE PROOF THAT
THE LIST OF PROBLEMATIC POSTS
THAT JEN PSAKI OR WHOEVER SENT
OVER TO THEM ARE ACTUALLY ONES
THAT GOT TAKEN DOWN.
THEY DO WORK WITH GOVERNMENT AND
NGOs AND OFFICIALS ALL OVER
THE WORLD TO MAKE SURE THEY ARE
KEEPING THE PLATFORMS AS SAFE AS
POSSIBLE.
THAT MEANS TO TAKE DOWN VIDEOS
THAT TERRORISTS ARE POSTING.
OKAY, WE'RE DONE.
>> Jesse: IT'S NOT TERRORISM
TO SAY OR NOT GETTING THE
VACCINE.
I SHOULD NEVER HAVE GIVEN YOU
THE LAST WORD.
[LAUGHTER]
DO YOU WANT TO SAY ONE MORE
THING?
YOU'RE MAKING ME FEEL THAT,
JESSICA!
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: IT'S GOOD TO SEE
DEMOCRATS FINDING A FLAG THE